Issoudun dans l'Indre est un cas d'école
en matière de désert médical cette ville
de 12000 habitants possède un bel
équipement avec cet hôpital de 500
litres ce qui manque ici ce sont les
médecins pour fonctionner
l'établissement a régulièrement recours
à des spécialistes intérimaires qu'il
doit payer au prix fort ici le
plafonnement de leur rémunération à une
conséquence immédiate le service
gériatrie
est mis à l'arrêt faute de médecin
Marisa
vous allez bien ce patient quittera les
lieux la semaine prochaine sont lits
comme les 17 autres du service restera
vides les patients restent le temps de
leur éducation dans tous les cas aucun
patient sera renvoyé chez lui avec par
manque de rééducation ou autre ça dans
tous les cas c'est pas convenable pour
le moment du coup il y a plus de
d'admission actuellement
donc du coup qu'on ne retrouve pas un
praticien
terrain on va dire au sein du soin de
suite gériatrique
c'est tout j'ai de la chance quoi
au nouveau tarif plafonné
1390 euros brut pour 24 heures aucun
spécialiste en gériatrie ne souhaitent
pour leur exercer à l'hôpital d'Issoudun
la direction ne peut plus jouer sur le
levier financier comme elle a souvent
été contraint de faire
on n'a jamais été dans la course à
l'échalotes on n'a jamais été sur des
rémunérations qu'on entend qui sont pour
le coup totalement exorbitante donc nous
on a certes dépassé les plafonds
autorisés mais de façon tout à fait
raisonnable
1800 de 1000 euros net pour le 24 heures
oui c'est arrivé avec des médecins qui
venaient qui nous montrait parfois les
propositions qu'ils avaient ailleurs en
nous disant en gros si vous alignez pas
on ne vient pas en plus de ces
rémunérations hautes l'hôpital offrait
aux intérimaires le logement dans ce
petit studio aménagé
une table tout est propre c'est pas très
moderne mais c'est très propre ils sont
coconés
c'est aussi logique c'est compris c'est
compris dans la prestation pour le
directeur le plafonnement était devenu
inéluctable
est absolument nécessaire pour sortir de
la situation
jusqu'au-boutiste dans laquelle tous les
directeurs d'hôpitaux étaient plongés
maintenant que cette loi s'applique sur
tout le territoire national forcément il
arrivera un moment où les intérimaires
reviendront à la raison et prétendront
rendez-vous à des salaires beaucoup plus
raisonnables pour fonctionner
normalement l'hôpital d'Issoudun
aimerait surtout recruter des médecins
permanents c'est le dénouement espéré
maintenant que l'intérim devient moins
lucratif